April the 30th 2016 a day for ordinary  folks to celebrate the phased removal of  surcharges for roaming a day when the  possibility of returning from holiday to  the phone bill from hell diminished for  years the European Parliament fought  member states and national telecoms  groups tooth and nail for reduced  roaming charges from April the 30th they  are added to the rates paid at home as  follows outgoing voice calls 5 euro  cents maximum on top of your domestic  contract rate text messages to euro  cents maximum on top of home rates  mobile data 5 euro cents maximum on top  of home rates  just over a year later on june the 15  2017 all these surcharges are eradicated  what you pay at home is what you will  pay abroad no more surcharges a giant  steps am eps towards the digital single  market there are exceptions for example  habitual travelers may have to pay extra